i have a a daughter who has a dog named
snoop i just i just met the dog in real
life yeah but y'all don't know me and
the dog just bonded he's a little cutie
isn't it yeah man he [ __ ] with me that's
my nephew man you instead me i'm the dog
father you know when the dog see me
either he come over to me and he rubbed
me or he lay on his back or if he just
sit down and just pee
like damn that snoop dogg
you're a real dog man
the way you came up to that little dog
and then he was like like froze and you
start petting him and he started giving
in to you and he posed for the picture
come on now joe who does that yeah what
the [ __ ] does for him it's like meeting
like a mythical god you've heard like
your namesake
your namesake is a bad he perhaps he's
in movies and you imagine you're a dog
you're trying to figure this out who am
i named after oh you've never have to
snoop do double g the real the
[ __ ] dog father the dog father
and when they see me say this that smell
like that smell like the dog father
oh
i'm shriveling timbers huh exit stage
love it must be the dog father i must
run up if he tried to explain to his
friends that he met the real snoop dogg
they'd be like shut the [ __ ] up you
lying i'm telling you how the [ __ ] you
mean snoop dog
down somewhere you ain't me no
[ __ ] snoop dogg
i met him dog i'm telling you
[ __ ] was scratching my back and
everything
[Music]